author and columnist mark Stein has been
following this too and he joins us
tonight
so mark typically you'd want to withhold
judgment on something like this because
you don't know what's in the letter but
here's what we do know
judge Kavanaugh went to high school at
Georgetown Prep in Bethesda Maryland if
there was a crime alleged 35 years later
presumably that would be referred to the
Maryland State Police were the local
police in Bethesda instead senator
Feinstein's Senate to the FBI federal
authorities would have no obvious
jurisdiction so that tells me right
there that this is a crock and it's the
worst kind of smear smear you can't
rebut against a man with the wife and
small children I'm not sure I've seen
anything lower ever no you're absolutely
right there as you say the FBI has no
obvious jurisdiction here I think in the
normal course of events given that this
is something to do with the Junior Prom
in Maryland in 1981 or 1979 or whatever
the hell it was it would be going to
juvenile court so this would be the
first United States Supreme Court
justice to be tried in juvenile court
I don't guide that's a that's a legal
first I think what we have here is
actually the equivalent of what happened
when Comey briefed the President on the
so-called steel dossier about Russian
hookers in his hotel women all the rest
of it and that gave the pretext to the
media because Comey then leaked news of
the meeting that gave the media a
pretext to discuss the dossier
likewise senator Feinstein releasing as
everyone said the secret letter from a
secret person about a secret matter
about the high school prom has now given
cover for a lot of sexual allegations we
don't know what they are they're they're
half a lifetime ago and as you say it's
not something that he can be rebutted
and the real battle here
Tucker is actually between Dianne
Feinstein and the new left they were
disappointed by the big-shot Democrat
dinosaurs performance in the hearing
rooms and they want something a little
more ante far a little more black lives
a little more Bernice and
and it's pathetic to see diane feinstein
and i know i've no idea what she did at
her high school prom however many years
ago that was it's pathetic to see diane
feinstein reduced to this
well it's disgusting and the dynamic you
described is exactly what's happening
the dinosaurs who were on their way out
in charge of that party are terrified
and they're responding to them up let me
ask you a question that seems reasonable
to me it'll probably spark protests
against me somehow but and i don't know
what the allegation is and I'm prepared
to withhold judgment on that but a 35
year old allegation if it exists that
has never been reported to the police
doesn't that at least raise the question
why is it never been reported assuming
it hasn't been yes it's actually I think
it's I think it's wrong to go back and
and relitigate a past you didn't
litigate at the time I think that's very
very dangerous you see that as part of
this moral panic that has gone on over
the me two things I mean if you go back
to the nearest comparable thing the
Clarence Thomas business that was at
within the previous decade we're we're
talking about something that was never
in very what the only reassuring thing
about this is that as you know
investigations are interminable in this
country and in Washington in particular
and the only good thing about this is
that the FBI has looked at it and kicked
it out of their purview in ten minutes
flat and good for them they're not
opening an investigation they've just
given it to the White House they don't
want to touch this
she's just collude she's just diminished
her own reputation by participating in
this man I've never met Brett cab no I
have no personal stake in this
whatsoever
but I don't think honestly I think the
any normal person should be offended by
this this is too much it's too low it's
described set absolutely it is and this
high school I gather this is where Neil
Gorsuch went to school too so apparently
it's where all Supreme Court judges
that's what it's the preparatory school
for so maybe maybe he did something at
his prom - maybe it all goes back to the
problem it's a little ridiculous that
all boys vote for whatever it's worth
mark Stein we'll see in just a minute
thank you for that thank